Привет! В прошлом уроке мы разобрали подходы. 5 способов взаимодействия с моделью. В каждом из них есть общий элемент — это prompt. Поэтому следующий шаг — разобрать сам prompt. Здесь есть один нюанс, который не виден на первый взгляд. В интерфейсе любой модели prompt пишется в одно поле, выглядит как просто фраза. Внутри этой фразы модель все равно различает несколько смысловых слотов, даже когда они не разделены явно. Если вы не управляете слотами сами, модель додумывает за вас и результат уже не представляет.
Второй нюанс — это формат записи. У разных архитектур, мы уже знаем, какие они бывают, разные требования к тому, как этот prompt построен. Где-то ключевые слова через запятую, где-то описательная речь — это разница вследствие того, как модель училась читать текст. Разберём и слоты, и формат. Итак, 5 слотов promptа. Первый — это субъект. Кто или что в кадре. Это главный объект сцены, персонаж, продукт, ландшафт. Без субъекта нормального promptа нет. Модели нужен якорь, на который
она все остальное навесит. Второй — это стиль. Эстетика, техника, возможно, какие-то конкретные примеры, там, фотографии, иллюстрации, 3D-рендер, акварель,
изометрия. Сюда же стилистические референсы в духе Весс Андерсон, как обложка ВОК, в эстетике плоского минимализма и так далее.
Стиль определяет визуальный язык всей картинки. Третий — это окружение, где происходит сцена. Локация, ее фон, то есть можно задавать
контекст, например, улица, студия, лес, абстрактный градиент. Окружение задает пространство и атмосферу. Без него
окружение субъекта получается скучным. Четвертое — это детали. Нюансы, которые не описаны в трех первых
слотах. Конкретные характеристики, там, цвет волос, материал поверхности, выражение лица, элементы одежды,
мелкие предметы в кадре и так далее. Этот слот самый длинный в большинстве промтов, поэтому именно здесь
живет уникальность сцены. И пятый — это технические параметры. Ракурс камеры, освещение, формат
кадра, разрешение, объектив. Сюда попадает то, как кадр снят. Общий план, крупный план, золотой час,
13-миллиметровый объектив, 16 на 9, 4К разрешение, HDR и так далее. Сюда я чаще всего описываю,
на что это было снято. То есть, например, широкоформатный объектив сделает изображение по краям
растянут. Также можно писать 35 миллиметров или на какое конкретно устройство снято, на какой-нибудь
пленочный кодек, чтобы снимки получились вайбовые. Модели все обучаются на огромном количестве
различных референсов. И даже если ты не можешь прям досконально описать, вот почему этот снимок
именно такой, почему он так круто выглядит на какую-нибудь классную камеру, просто укажи, что это за камера,
и он уже сам поймет, в чем этот стиль заключается. Это 5 самых основных деталей промпта.
Если не знаешь, с чего начать, идешь просто по порядку, каждый из этих слотов заполняя.
И отдельно еще хочу отметить, что под каждый слот ты можешь находить референсы.
Заходишь на тот же Pinterest, ищешь интересный объект, ищешь интересный стиль, ищешь интересное окружение,
детали и так далее. И в качестве мультиреференса закидываешь все.
Берем методику мультиреференс, все это закидываем и описываем.
Субъект с первого кадра, стиль со второго, окружение с третьего, и таким образом формируем что-то уникальное.
Вот как 5 слотов могут выглядеть в одном промпте.
Субъект. Одинокая фигура на краю скалы, стиль.
Кинематографичная пейзажная фотография, окружение.
Высокий обрыв над океаном, дальний горизонт, детали.
Длинные тени, ветер в одежде, теплая палитра золотого часа, технические.
Также общий план, низкий ракурс, 13-миллиметровый объектив, формат 16 на 9.
Но здесь уже в разных моделях где-то нужно писать формат, где-то его можно сразу задать.
Повторюсь, это 5 основных деталей, которые нужны для построения промпта.
Если каждую из них мы заполнили, мы точно знаем, что мы хотим видеть.
У нас не получится какого-то ненужного креатива в нашем конечном результате.
Вот в качестве примера я закинул этот промпт и воспроизвел изображение.
Как видишь, каждый раз оно плюс-минус одинаковое.
Каждый раз оно одинаковое.
Почему? Потому что мы вообще все, что можно было, в этом промпте затронули.
Таким образом мы полностью контролируем генерацию и можем предсказуемые результаты получать.
Также отдельно отметим главное правило заполнения этих самых слотов.
Это конкретность.
Слова «красивый», «качественный», «стильный», «современный», «крутой» для модели не несут информации.
Или несут, но у нее представление о том, что круто, осталось на уровне 2015 года.
Например, если ты GPT-имидж напишешь «сделай мне крутой премиальный сайт»,
ну, скорее всего, это будет кожа, золото, ну, что-то максимально цыганское.
Если раньше, когда-то это производило впечатление, сейчас уже нет, но, тем не менее, на этом обучен чат GPT.
А каких-то старых форматов, старых изображений всегда будет больше, чем самых актуальных.
Соответственно, именно они будут формировать представление модели о том, что актуально,
что конкретно подразумевается под тем или иным абстрактным понятием.
А вот какие-то более конкретные вещи она запросто воспроизводит.
Золотой час, низкий ракурс, теплая палитра.
Потому что миллион таких изображений видела в обучении и понимает, что конкретно под этим паттерном ты подразумеваешь.
Поэтому принцип простой.
Каждая оценочная прилагательная в промпте — это упущенный шанс задать конкретику.
Если хочется написать «красивый закат», спроси себя, а что именно делает закат красивым в твоем кадре?
Цвета? Тогда оранжево-розовый градиент в небе, силуэт на фоне, перьевые облака и так далее.
Если свет, то какой именно контурный, может быть, естественное освещение, может быть, это золотой час, очень распространенный прием.
Если речь о композиции, то, опять же, какая?
Вид с утеса, низкая линия горизонта, силуэт фигуры в правой трети или, например, симметричная композиция.
То есть более конкретно описываем.
То же самое касается конкретных объектов.
То есть если мы хотим иконку, не пишем «красивая иконка», пишем «плоская монохромная иконка», «обводка 2 пикселя», «мягкие скругления» и так далее.
То, что, на твой взгляд, делает ее красивой.
Ну и, опять же, в качестве примера интерьер, все то же самое, современный интерьер.
Какой он современный интерьер? Что сейчас современно?
Описываем это и получаем предсказуемый хороший результат.
И еще одна тонкость, которую модели не подсвечивают.
Порядок слов имеет значение.
Модели читают промпт сверху вниз, сначала к концу, и сильнее всего влияет на конечный результат то, что стоит в самом начале.
Особенно это заметно в диффузионных моделях.
У авторегрессивных моделей, ну, опять же, такие, как там Nano Banana 2, например, или GPT Image, порядок тоже важен, но там это работает намного мягче.
Поэтому фиксируем самое главное у нас в первой трети промпта.
Теперь про формат самого промпта.
Один и тот же набор слотов можно записать по-разному, и разные модели читают тоже это по-разному.
Возвращаемся к архитектурам, которые мы разбирали на старте модуля, диффузионные и гибридно-авторегрессивные.
Здесь это особенно важно.
Диффузионные модели, такие как Mid Journey, Stable Diffusion и ее ветки, обучались на парах изображения текст,
где текст часто был короткой меткой или набором тегов.
Из-за этого они отлично читают тег-формат.
Ключевые слова через запятую без длинных предложений.
Веса элементов, то есть то, насколько важно их отобразить, насколько точно эти элементы нужно воспроизвести на изображении, отображаются через двоеточие.
Например, скала двоеточие 2, там точно должна быть скала Ocean, двоеточие 0.5, там может быть не сильно много океана на этом изображении.
То есть тем самым мы говорим о второстепенности этого объекта в кадре.
Технические параметры в Mid Journey передаются через флаги, аспект 3, то есть, например, соотношение сторон, аспект 3, ставим 2 дефиса, AR и пишем 16 на 9, 4 на 3 и так далее.
Референс персонажа сериев мы уже это смотрели.
Более подробно о том, как формировать промпты, какие у нас вообще есть модели взаимодействия с Mid Journey мы посмотрим отдельно в уроке, посвященном конкретно этой модели.
Гибридные авторегрессивные модели, такие как Nano Banana, GPT Image, построены на языковой модели уровня Gemini или GPT.
Внутри них есть полноценный текстовый процессор, и они понимают речь как речь.
Длинные описательные предложения с условиями работают там лучше тегов.
Когда вы пишете, там, нарисую в интерьере какой-нибудь постер, чтобы он был на кириллице, оттенок постера контрастировал с фоном,
модель воспринимает это уже как инструкцию и конкретно воспроизводит то, что вы описали.
Удерживает все ваши вводные.
Но эти модели, как правило, быстро они генерируют и достаточно дорогие по токенам.
На этот случай у нас есть пограничный вариант Flux, в частности, второй версии.
Это диффузионная модель, но с продвинутым языковым энкодером.
То есть она понимает фразы, но и теги тоже читает.
Это самая удобная модель для тех, кто переходит между разными подходами.
Но мы знаем, что на двух стульях не усидишь, поэтому она не дает стилистически такой же крутой результат, как Mid Journey,
того же уровня контроля, как авторегрессивные модели, там, нано-бананы или GPT.
Соответственно, вроде как может и то, и другое, но делает это попроще.
И вот тот пример промпта, который я ранее описывал со скалой, с пейзажем, как он будет выглядеть в разном формате.
Тег-формат, языковой формат, либо пограничный.
В тег-формате у нас идет через конкретное перечисление того, что мы хотим там видеть.
В языковом формате можно описывать как угодно.
И плюс также в том, что ты можешь продолжать диалог с агентом, говорить,
нет, давай еще добавим немного света и получить, по сути, плюс-минус тоже изображение,
но с изменениями, которые ты только что попросил сделать.
Если ты работаешь с диффузионной моделью в Миджорне, например, это невозможно.
Ты не можешь поддерживать диалог, дорабатывать.
Ты меняешь именно промпт, добавляешь что-то в него и надеешься, что в этот раз будет лучше.
Ну и пограничный формат, опять же, можно как угодно вводить,
но на практике, если ты используешь описательную речь, результат получается поинтереснее.
Итак, когда промпта достаточно?
Одноразовые задачи, там, один баннер, одна иллюстрация, один эксперимент,
быстрой проверки идеи, поиск стиля, когда нужно нагенерировать варианты и выбрать направление.
Здесь промпт-инженеринг закрывает почти все.
Когда промпта перестает хватать, когда нам нужны серии в одном стиле,
каждый раз набирать один и тот же длинный промпт неудобно, ненадежно
и не всегда результат получается предсказуемый все равно.
Также, когда нам нужна воспроизводимость, нам нужно повторить результат через месяц
с тем же объектом или, например, другим, но в той же стилистике.
И когда нам нужна командная работа, когда мы хотим, чтобы в одной и той же стилистике
несколько человек генерировали, тут передавать из рук в руки просто промпта,
писательный или набор тегов, тоже было бы странно.
Работать одинаково у всех вряд ли будет.
И чтобы закрыть эти проблемы, есть один определенный формат промпта.
Это JSON промпты.
В следующем уроке мы разберем, как переводить промпт из фразы в JSON,
какие поля туда класть, почему это решает проблему серии и воспроизводимости.
А также посмотрим на конкретном примере, как это работает.
На этом все. Увидимся в следующем уроке.